hi i'm ryan right and i'm marie welcome
to the channel guys if you're new so a
lot of people were recommending i check
out this trailer for the Lego Batman 3
beyond Gotham now let me first start off
by saying can I say something real fast
Murray sorry for touching your wrist you
got HIV in my hand so dang it oh yeah
yeah I played the first one it's fun and
I like Batman in the lego movie was
really [ __ ] cool so yeah you played
it I've played a lego starwars which was
right when the first one came out it
looked really stupid and it was so good
but I'm confident but if it is anything
like like a star with a man as long as
you have that confidence this really
counts that's the key to being
successful it's confidence lion look at
this [ __ ] look at these eyes [ __ ]
confidence right here [ __ ]
that's rude awkward
expanse of darkness
well it looks like fun there's no
gameplay there every but it looks like
fun
oh yeah me neither I don't know do you
think maybe you'd get to play I think so
that would be really fun da fun if you
could play a Superman
oh damn go zip it around I mean be fun
to plays the Green Lantern and get the
you know what did they should they
should make a Wii game or a Kinect game
where you're Superman dude very so much
fun you know Murray I make fun of you a
lot but I really do love you sweetie
your hair smells okay today really you
do yeah are you sure well thanks guys
for recommending that trailer um ya know
looks like a cute little game I want I
want to play it I love anything Batman
related anything mmm such a [ __ ] idiot
how can I wear my Superman shirt every
single Batman video and I got my Batman
EJ's on still anyway if you're new to
the channel get off the streets I am
it's tough out here we're too poor man
we're too [ __ ] bore our apartments
cost more than either of us should be
pain yeah and I spend more than I can
afford on many things
mmm drugs the occasional alcohol a lot
of cocaine a lot of cocaine yeah yeah
now dude [ __ ] go games awesome I
would I would do more cocaine and
but we don't have cocaine money yeah we
don't know mu to pitch in we're gonna
start a kickstart what do you think the
energy comes from these trailer
reactions people so what you're gonna
see pretty soon next videos we're gonna
put up a Kickstarter for cocaine cocaine
we're gonna start a business kind of
like you'd call it like a cartel that
we're gonna start selling cocaine so we
can have more cocaine we're gonna get
more code came to you the subscribers
we want everybody to have cocaine on we
want to make a better cocaine we don't
want to like cut it with nothing so
we're gonna there's gonna be a
Kickstarter campaign for that coming
soon you're gonna see it what are we
gonna call it um the the cocaine Express
it could have been better Polar Express
The Polar Express Express we're gonna
run this all through trains none of them
are gonna go to the North Pole but
there's gonna be a lot of stuff for some
links now you can embed Santa sometimes
stress you get that [ __ ] there's gonna
be a man dressed as Santa there should
be a charity that gives cocaine to
children they should come with silver
bells so I wanted to give some shoutouts
Marie just it's a sudden feeling that
just kicked in you know I I never do
these any but that's that's what you're
the man idea guy i'm the idea guy and
the face guy I'm also a tits and ass
kind of guy you know what I mean oh baby
oh baby look eat that money out my I was
talking with Kathy other day and she was
telling me about when someone's like I
want to tear that [ __ ] up and how
horrible that sounds doesn't that sound
disgusting sounds painful the image she
put in my mind was like I am never gonna
use that phrase again that sounds like
those urban legends you hear about like
people going to the ER after their
boyfriend like like woman going to the
ER when their boyfriend has braces I'll
let you draw your own conclusions to
what happens in those stories mega x1
for one
he said on the spoiler review for x-men
Days of Future past good review Ryan can
you please give me a shout-out please
mega X 141 I bring you a shout out from
the real rejects you are anointed as one
of the Savior's I'm sorry can you
imagine our landlord coming dude he's
not a young man
you'd probably talk for a lot of the
masturbation Big Show junior one two
three can you give me a shout-out and
can you sub to me and I live in Sigma
poor good fatty Sigma port Singapore
Singapore Singapore it's not signa port
no well Johnny Depp got it wrong in
Pirates of the Caribbean Bri look I know
it's been tough for you but I'm here to
tell you that everything's gonna be okay
yeah don't ever put your head on my
shoulder for that amount of time again
Oh Junior sorry I got carried away there
dude I'm gonna subscribe to your channel
I'm excited to see what it's about you
might have to remind me to do that cuz
you know some people think like there
are people who just go with the [ __ ] man
you said you're gonna upload this video
what happened to that video they don't
realize like I film several videos and
then I you know spread it out does it
take something to put videos together
and edit yeah so I might not run jump
cut yeah yeah I mean like I don't know
when this video is gonna come out man
but hey hey you just remind me subscribe
to your channel and I might do it one
day one day maybe if I care enough
Elenore plus this is a special lady she
didn't ask for a shout-out she's really
hot Joss we do a review of movie called
the zombie ex who she's really hot she's
very hot how you doing
kidding tits yeah kidding tits well I
didn't
what's kidding
dude that was amazing I wish you got
that on camera dude oh man the second
you saw you just smashed it that was
awesome with your own hands oh you're
disgusting
unless you bro like let me get a shoe
like that you don't even do the clap
that's beautiful mm-hmm that's beautiful
I realize I'll be an [ __ ] if I don't
shout someone else out does that person
didn't ask for one reg betta he's
head-on the equalizer trailer reaction
video that's the best trailer reaction
ever and he said do a damn Hercules
international trailer reaction all
[ __ ] ready you guys give shots to
people who aren't subscribed oh and one
more then Lauren Sally Veronica can't
even Murray don't give me a shout-out in
sexy voice give me a blowout
why is even and even [ __ ] you
[ __ ] with the wrong girl that's why yeah
madam adieu to you I'd say yeah that's
your tires right there mm-hmm she's back
it's gonna go flat yeah and I know she's
very brittle you don't want a hugger too
tight it's possible fatal hug yeah every
time she high-fives me her life
decreases by one day up just lust one
day of my life rang